welcome back to PJ CH Design This is PJ
today we are going to talk about how to
making this eternity ring espcially how
to calculate the stone for specific ring
size and the pr distance are you ready
let's get
[Music]
started we're going to starting uh bring
in the stone and size to the size that
you like for your jewelry you can
download the file at the description
below or you can watch uh one of my
diamond making video to know how to make
this diamond once you get the stone
that's coming into the front view and
I'm going to set it up a ring size for
16 um so we want to see that how many
Stone do we need it for this one I'm
going to use the uh array polar and I'm
going to type it zero here and kind of a
guessing let's guess 20 and see how that
works
it seems really well so now we are
looking at this Stone the stone is about
2 and a half roughly about that size and
you actually want it to have a little
bit distance in between you do not want
it to be too close because the prong
will be really small so we want to
measure the size for this one if we
coming over snapping into the vertex
from this point to this end point here
and we can roughly know that it's like
46 mm all right so that is nice and that
is the smallest area which mean our
prong will be cutting about 20% and that
that's actually pretty good so coming at
the front view I'm going to draw
snapping from this vertex to this vertex
and I'll draw a line there and I'm going
to coming into the front view that's
starting from the zero and snapping into
the midpoint of that line and I also
wanted to have another one coming here
just snapping into the quadrant here so
now we can know like how much is
different in between those as using the
dimension tool measure one more time
this time we want to measure in between
here and
here and it is showing it's 0 degree or
simply you can just 360 / by 20 anyway
so I'm going to use this as a guideline
later on so I'm I'm need to have a
reference line over there okay the next
things what we wanted to do it's
actually draw a straight
line and I'm moving my cursor to this uh
straight line here and tap hit the uh
tap key and coming out like this so this
line will be the correct Angle now I
need to copy this line to the other side
over here or since this this is 18°
twice I'm going to making a copy by
rotation and copy equal yes here and I
want to type it
36 so then I will have uh one here and
one here to making a curve uh nicely in
between those two line what I like to do
is using the blank command I'm going to
blend it in between here and here so you
can hold the shift key and moving this
back so it will move on the both
uh handle together and I want to have
something roughly maybe like this so
this will be the line that I'm going to
use maybe it is a little bit too
long because I do not want to have my
prong is like Too Tall so I'm going to
join them and then uh going to draw a
Arc maybe
from this point to over this point and
use that as a cutting tool to trim this
off so then that will be a proper size
of the prong okay so now we need to edit
something like this now if I just go
ahead and pipe this
guy and let say we wanted to have a
radius 4.5 mm which is a little bit fat
there but we will change it later and um
I say I'm going to move this one to here
right so what happen to the next one is
going to look like this we are going to
do a test by rotating this one and
moving something like this right now
notice that if you in the render View
and what you're going to see is this
really ugly transition there right so to
make it look nicer we need to have some
is lower some is higher so something
like this
so it will look nicer but now if you
look at the top view so all those four
point four prong is not a line so it
doesn't look good in this way so what I
like to do is
this I'm going to rebuild this
guy and you can rebuild as many point as
you want it I'm going to try uh seven
point here and click okay now somewhere
around here and here those two point I
want them to move in a little bit and
maybe this one want to move in a little
bit more something like that right so if
we pipe in this
one it was a little bit too big for 05
radius let's try
04 and click enter twice so then you get
something like this all right so we want
to give it a try and see how that look
I'm going to have this one
and rotate
it from this point
for
18° and we can take a look on this and
see if that's working fine all right so
if that working fine and then we're
going to use uh this as a guideline but
also you can do another way is you can
move this one out
first like this and I'm going to pipe
this one and make sure you turn on the
history with the same diameter like this
okay the next one we are going to do is
we're going to do polar array and uh
Center is zero polar array 20 of them
and again make sure you record a
history so you will get something like
this and you can take a look on the
render view all right so if that is
something that you like then that's fine
but if you don't like it what you can do
is you can turn on the control point of
this curve and then you keep editing on
it because we record a history so
everybody will change at the same time
okay so let's say you like this
one so all we need to do now is to
mirror to the other side all right so it
look good right now but the two sides
actually not touching right so we cannot
cast something like this so next let's
uh just making a bar in between I'm just
going to draw a very short line and
having this guy to be pipe with the same
diameter there and with this one I
actually want it to
be a line Center and just type it zero
there okay now I can just simply moving
this one to the
top where is connected I actually wanted
to make this one just slightly smaller
so it's the line the seam is doesn't um
overlapping and creating a problem for
buling unit and with this one let's
polar rate the same
number for 20 of them and now I'm
looking at this actually this is a good
opportunity to talk about that we
actually don't want to have a colol of a
stone is stick it into something all
this bar that we have here
we actually want them to move it right
here so that way we can make the back of
the stone is clear let's do polar array
one more time and 20 of
them and that way we'll make sure the
bar is clean uh if you like to trim it
out inside to be more flat that should
show you more of a stone you can do that
too or the Jeweler actually will do that
anyway when they set the stone it is
really important understand how the
stone setting work for jewelry cat
design if you want to know more about
the stone setting I have a completely
free course it is a stone setting mini
course starting from talking about the
stone setting concept and I will show
you what's the crucial element to design
a pron set and we will custom a pron set
hat in this mini course I hope that will
help you to understand the stone setting
better for the jewelry cat design the
link is in the description below hope to
see you there and thank you for watching
I'll see you next
[Music]